heads up guys my name is Jenna and today
we are going to be talking about events
and we're going to actually write a
quick project which includes an event
dispatcher and an event system to
basically play around with this and see
how it works so first of all what is an
event an event is it can be many things
okay it's essentially just something
that happens throughout our game or our
application that we want to actually
report to various different entities
okay so for example if the user clicks
the mouse on something we usually want
to be like hey everyone who is
subscribed to this kind of event system
the user just clicked on a mouse or the
user just clicked his nails on her mouse
on a certain object or something like
that yeah usually you would you would
kind of provide data such as what which
mouse button was pressed no the location
of the click all of that kind of stuff
and then the entity that is subscribed
to that event system into that
particular event the mouse press event
for example they would receive all that
data and they'll also get notified hey
this happened right and the upside to
this is that you don't actually need to
check right so instead of kind of doing
polling we're pretty much doing
interrupting so what I mean by that is
previously or I guess any other way to
do it would be for example to you know
in your entities update method be like
hey if the mouse is pressed right and
the button is left then I want to do
this okay that is basically you querying
the mouse so you're like hey mouse where
you are right what we're going to be
doing is kind of the other the other way
around
so whenever the mouse does get pressed
we actually tell the entity hey the
mouse kept the mouse got pressed and in
the SD can do whatever he or she wants
right so the idea is that this is also
very very useful not just for kind of I
guess cleaning everything up and making
it look a bit nicer as well as not
having to continually query what's
actually
happening with the system right you
actually get notified instead above from
that stuff it's also very important for
concepts like layers because what
happens is that if you have two layers
and you can just picture them as layers
in Photoshop or something if you have
two layers on top of each other and you
only want you obviously want to handle
events for the one that's on top first
and then halfway through you might not
want to continue right so for example if
I have a box on top of another box right
if I have a panel of another panel and I
want to I want to maybe implement some
kind of functionality where when you
click and drag it moves the panel that
your mouse is on right how do I figure
out which panel I'm actually moving so
this is probably a bit of a terrible
example but um no sorry it's a very good
example I just it's very very well let's
say you've got a panel you've got this
red panel excuse me
it goes red panel and then you've got
this okay and only it's a it's an
ellipse but anyway you've got this in
this right when you put your mouse over
the the blue lips right you want to
maybe click and drag and it will just
move the blue lips however when you put
your mouse over this red thing for
example you might want to move that so
basically what I'm saying is how do how
do we handle that right how do we say
that that if these are on separate
layers and I move to the front layer how
do I do that without affecting the back
layer right because what you could do is
you could do like a bit of a ray cast
and figure out where the mouse is of a
witch and there now it's really messy
right now
yeah we don't want to do that okay
instead we have them on separate layers
the blue lifts on the layer in front of
the red rectangle right and all that
happens is once you handle it mouse
click event if it is inside the bounds
you kind of tell the event dispatcher
hey I've handled the mouse press event
do not propagate it to the rest of the
layers okay anyway there's a lot of
there's there's a huge speech I could
give you guys about events and whatnot
but we're not going to do that we're
just gonna kind of implement a system
now unfortunately I am starting from
scratch so this video
might be a bit longer than I would have
hoped it to be but I'm going to try and
rush through most of the kind of
boilerplate code okay but essentially
we're actually going to start with
events we're going to kind of start with
the beds and then we'll kind of create
like a little sandbox to play around
with so I'll make a new class or to put
this into like events now I'll call it
event okay so this is going to represent
all that events there's going to be a
base class that you will essentially
have to extend right so if you wanted to
you could make it abstract what I'll
actually go as you add any abstract
methods into this but you can make it
our structure so people can't
instantiate it kind of the same way as
if you made the constructor private I
guess so first of all we'll let everyone
creative attack read an event who
extends from this class right and then
we'll usually take in some kind of event
type which we need to create this will
just be an enum now this is actually one
of those things that would have been
much easier to demonstrate in c-sharp
rather than Java just because that
language supports a lot more a lot more
things than Java but I'm going to try my
best so we'll handle three events here
press release and moved so if you guys
are okay with this I might actually do
future videos in c-sharp demonstrating
stuff like this because it's a lot
better but regardless okay so we've got
a basic kind of system going on here all
I'm going to do apart from this is just
be able to basically see what type an
event is so I'll have a get type which
is returns type that's it that's
actually all I'm going to add into this
event class that's it okay so we have
three event types that we've explicitly
stated and as we add more we have to add
them to this to this list this item
we've let every subclass create a new
event right so only a subclass can run
this constructor okay which actually
might not work at all because it's
abstract anyway I don't even know man
but yeah it actually won't work let's
let's instead make a that's actually
totally fine by the way because I forgot
that we were writing and constructive so
that
okay anyway we've made a we've let every
subclass instantiate events by calling
its constructor and then we finally got
a public yet type so that anyone can see
what an event is so for example right
I'll make I'll make like a mousemove
event for example so we'll make a new
folder called tights okay and then in
types I'll make like a mouse moves
events so this will extend events we'll
go ahead and implement the alan porter
first of all i'm will implement a
constructor okay so when we move the
mouse we usually want about you know
three let's just say three parameters we
want the X the Y of what a mouse
currently is we might also take in
whether or not it was dragged when it
was moved okay
so pretty simple here I'll just still
make all this stuff public we've got X Y
and drat
you probably shouldn't make a public
just because I'm yelling on the cover
because obviously we don't want to be
able to change this but I'm actually
going to the first time ever use
eclipses generate getters and setters
thing so to get as likeness yeah
easy okay so the type is going to be
type dot event type thought okay sure I
just don't tell me I got this mouse
moves all right don't make that no okay
cool there we go so this is an example
event okay what happens is when you
instantiate this you give the right data
this should be public by the way you
give it the correct data and then it
sets the data all right and then anyone
who has access to it to the to an
instance of this essentially gets to see
all this information okay and that's
pretty much it all right there should be
a balloon so there we go we're done with
this class so that's an example of that
for you guys alright since we're here we
might as well kind of make the rest of
the events so
I'm just going to make I'm just going to
actually make a kind of intermediate
event called a mouse button event which
will extend at that because button
events like the release the release and
press events are very very similar
okay so we'll have something like a
Boston that like at the button key code
the button code and then we'll have the
location of the build the press right
and will actually make us protected as
well and then all just will take in is
the button the X the Y and since this is
going to be a subclass wall so take in a
type-o event then we'll call super with
the type and then we'll set the rest of
this stuff up this dot x equals x this
double y equals y all right
brilliant so there we go I'll generate
some getters and you know I'm making
these protective because they will be
changed
possibly they actually probably won't be
we could have made them private but it's
okay because we might want them so get
is done all right awesome
so there we go that's our mouse button
event now we have two more we have a
pressed event which of course now is
going to be basically no code at all
because it will simply extend a mouse
button event that's actually all we have
to do except instead of type we're going
to manually set the type to be event
type dots mouse press import that okay
and then we're going to do the exact
same thing for Mouse released obviously
if this wasn't Charla we would put all
these classes into one file but hey you
can't do that in Java because you know
who would want to do that with all right
so here we go I don't know why I did not
manage to do that all right
released so you can see how simple this
is
these pluses are actually exactly the
same the only difference is the the
event type okay because I've made this
kind of intermediate class which extends
event which handles pretty much
everything in them we just put the type
in here okay
because release and press events are
basically the same they just kind of you
know whether or no it was released or
pressed so there we go that's how I been
system that's actually pretty much all
we need in terms of events okay now we
can get onto the meaty stuff and the
meaty stuff is essentially the event
dispatcher system okay but that is that
is the event system so it's pretty
simple all it is is classes which
represent certain events taking place
okay and they have a type and that's it
that's kind of my summary all right so
let's make a class that is essentially
the event dispatcher so what's going to
happen is we'll also make an interface
called event listener okay and what this
means what an event listener is is any
anyone who wants to substitute anyone
who wants to subscribe to event so
anyone who wants to be notified of
events taking place
okay needs to basically implement the
event listener interface so in the event
listener interface we have a public
boolean on events okay and it takes in
the like an an event as a parameter okay
and that's it so the reason it's a
boolean is because we're actually going
to be able to return true or false based
on whether or not we want further
I guess further event subscribers to
actually process that event so I'll show
you guys how that works a bit later on
so what happens in the event dispatcher
is we set we set one of these up every
time we get an event okay and the event
dispatcher is basically those of what it
says right is a dispatcher so what it
does is it dispatches the event into the
appropriate handler based on its type
that's it so it's basically a really
easy way for us
be like hey I want to handle Mouse
events with this method I want to handle
you know key press events with this
method and then the dispatcher is like
okay cool so whenever I get events I'll
tell you where to go
so public event dispatcher events event
so this sort of N equals event and then
we'll have a public voice dispatch okay
which will basically take you in an
event type and an event so listener and
will actually make one more will make
one more class here actually maybe we
should make it an interface yeah I think
we should so event handler this is
actually going to be pretty much the
same as I almost don't want to make this
because it's going to be kind of the
same thing as the listener except to
avoid event I'll call it event analog it
doesn't actually matter what it's going
to be cold really and then there we go
okay public Toyota Panhandle that's just
what it's got that's basically the
method is going to dispatch it to now we
don't even have to actually ever
instantiate it because we're using Java
8 so I'm just gonna use lambdas for all
of this but just something to keep in
mind so anyway with this basically the
first thing we have to do is check to
save the event has been handled already
that's where that bullying comes in
that's an event listener if this returns
true that means the event has been
handled okay if the event has been
handled okay did I put that into event
no I didn't so we need to have a
bullying that's essentially handled okay
so every event has a every event has a
bullying right that which states whether
all has been handled or not okay now
I've set this to be not private or
public okay if you do not set a
visibility modifier it essentially means
it's going to be only visible to this
package
because I do want event handler to
access this and write to it so I won't
read write access but I don't want
anything else to do it so anything in
main which is like the naam not the
event API right is a sandbox that
shouldn't be able to see handled it
might want to see what handled is but it
definitely shouldn't be modifying it
okay so setting it to kind of neutral or
default is the pro strategy so event if
event dot handled will return so we're
not going to handle anything that's
returned otherwise this is where the
types come in right if the event type
actually equals the type that we're
trying to handle with this dispatch then
we simply we essentially want to set up
and handle but we also the main thing
we're doing is sorry there should be
event handler and I'll call it handler
will basically just run the what was it
event handler event all right
like honestly I'm going to change this
to an event because it kind of it's a
bit weird okay cool so there we go so
basically interface event handler it has
on event and also you can see listener
has on event as well but the other
difference is one returns to pull in the
other one returns a void essentially
okay there's a real difference it's good
to have two interfaces though just
because they do mean different things an
event handle is very different from a
listener okay so there we go right and
then this oh sorry my bad
this should totally return a boolean
they are actually exactly the same to be
honest so you know all do we will
actually combine them because if they're
exact the same if you were really cool
and you were really kind of a I don't
know an object-oriented program or or
something you might create two events
with different names to do is I think
I'm not going to do that though so
it's cool okay so there we go
the actual difference right is the fact
that an event listener should really
return void because it's no we're never
going to query it okay so I am actually
going to kind of undo what I did and
give me a break guys it's like 8:00 a.m.
and will create a another one called
event listener okay which actually is
the same as this but it returns for it
because there's no need for us to return
anything from an event so annoyed and
this should be an interface there's no
real is no need for us to return
anything from a from an event listener
because it's just that doesn't matter
that's not actually the event there we
go done so that's the event system
pretty much done that's actually all you
need to implement this okay I could stop
the video here but obviously I haven't
shown you how this works um but what I
mean is we're basically done okay so how
do we create a balance how do we
generate this stuff so what I'll do
quickly is I'll actually set up a window
class okay we'll put it in the call
package here this will basically extend
jframe okay I'm gonna kind of rush
through this really quickly because this
is not what the video is about so we'll
set the title name it's a 4k frame will
add we'll have to set up some kind of
screen in a minute but set default close
operation Geoffrey makes it I'm close
we'll set up the window
and we'll set visible it's true okay so
what happens is we're going to quickly
make a canvas so that we can actually
draw some graphics on the screen a
colder canvas screen okay so the screen
is just our graphics kind of drawing
thing we'll look down to canvas alright
I'll just add a suppressor warnings for
this so we'll have a buffer strategy
we'll have a graphics object when we
create the screen we will take a size
for it we don't really need the size for
it we do need a size for it for clearing
but to be honest that'll be kind of sad
so we will set aside for it over here
we'll have an init which just creates a
buffer strategy so that we can actually
double bother this sort of triple
buffering doesn't really matter if we
have a single buffer will see flickering
begin rendering okay that will just
basically begin everything so it'll set
out parameters here so we'll get the
buffer strategy and we will set G 2 BBS
get draw graphics
okay let's import all this stuff a lot
of code here and I am rushing through
okay so clear so we'll just clear this
to white again and this is the making
like some kind of API here so I'm not
going to take in parameters for
everything here this is just to
demonstrate this zero zero get with get
height
we'll have a public void and rendering
which just basically disposes everything
that's kind of like a flush that's
pretty much it there should also be yet
a graphics object which will return J
okay there we go
basic spray so we'll add the screen
which we haven't made yet I will make it
right here and we'll pack the frame so
that it basically will adjust the size
of the frame to match the screen or to
fit the screen and that is pretty much
it as far as the screen goes so we've
got a rendering surface now is great
we'll add the others all in it it and
I'll call this run method so the way we
can run pretty well in swing because we
do want to obviously process events as
well it's pretty simple what we do is we
essentially want a while true loop but
instead of that what I'm going to write
with a semi recursive function so we'll
clear the screen will begin around
ring.look will clear the screen will
probably run the on render method which
we haven't actually written yet with the
graphics object get graphics object so
we'll have a private avoid on render so
this will basically call graphics this
will basically call all of our layers of
random methods and then we'll end
rendering
okay now just for fun we'll sleep for
about three milliseconds it's just so
we're not using too much I will have to
cash some crap for that okay and then
finally we need to keep rendering so the
best way to do this is just to invoke
the to use the invoke later so invoke
later the reason in my play basically
our goal is just to do that right so one
wait so we keep rendering but the
problem is this isn't on a separate
thread if we did have it on a separate
thread we might run into problems with a
few things because we're multi-threading
swinging and that's not a good strategy
usually so what we can do instead is we
can still run out on a single thread but
you swing swing utilities invoke later
what that will do is just invoke this
stuff and we could just use the lambda
for this it'll invoke this stuff after
its processed to all the events and
whatnot
so basically our window will still be
responsive and everything it's just what
you won't do this straightaway right if
we keep running this code the windows
never gonna get a chance to process
events such as mouse clicks or whether
always close or do all this other
internal stuff right because it'll be
blocked so that's really important thing
to do now we've got this rendering thing
now we basically just need an on event
thing which is actually what's going to
do our event stuff and finally we also
need actually that's pretty much it I
don't think we need anything else I mean
we have to talk about layers in a minute
but I think that's about it yeah cool so
that wasn't too difficult layers
what are layers so layers make a class
called layer pop it into the layers
package layers are just layers of
graphics essentially so we'll implement
event listener which means that we need
to have the on event notice this is the
one that returns void okay we can it
kind of implemented here without
actually doing much but will have an
on/off to it which we want I'll use I'm
on the adding this stuff just
kind of maybe makes more sense for you
guys they will have a non render a
renderer which is just a graphic subject
that's all that it needs
okay so I'll make an example layer out
here now sound box so that's not part of
the API I would say what it stands
layout for that and then we'll actually
talk about everything pretty much that
okay as far as all of that stuff goes so
let's talk about how now now we've got
layers and whatnot we into it we need to
essentially add a layer stack to our
window so this layer stack is just going
to be a list so we'll call it so we'll
have full layer stack it's just going to
be an array list though stacks and Java
a bit weird and in fact we really don't
need to use the stack for this list is
actually what we need what we want so
what we do is we when we added it we can
add layers right and just for debugging
and whatnot Oliver I will print out the
name of it and my name I just mean like
hash basically so we can see what which
object it is which is since it is okay
and then on event now here's here's the
difference this is a nice little
difference and this video is kind of
turning into more of a layer window but
sorry I lay a video but hopefully we
won't do too much on that maybe I
should've made a last layer video first
but basically what we want bit layers
and events kind of go hand in hand
that's why I'm doing it so yeah
basically we process our we process our
rendering normally yeah so we just we
kind of do that normally and all we
really do is we call the for each of
these layers we're calling layer stack I
don't um Brenda but no like this isn't
helping me out here all right
forgot about Java and its lack of
overloaded operators so there we go it
calls on render for each of these layers
and you can see just does it in order
however on event kind of does it the
other way around
it does look from top to bottom so from
bottom to top I care because obviously
we want to handle events for layers
which are closer to us which are
overlapping everything else first so the
way we do that is we can just set this
equal to layered or stacked size minus
one okay as long as I is greater than or
equal to zero and then I - - so now it's
basically iterating through the list in
reverse order okay and we'll just call
on events with events okay so events get
raised in the opposite kind of order
okay so from top to bottom rather than
from bottom to top which is how we
render things so there we go they're
different now as far as our actual
events go the way we can add events is
we can obviously just add you know Javas
add mouth noise now make sure you add
this to screen obviously not to our
window because the screen is was
rendering on top of the window we'll
just create a new mouse adapter and the
one the methods I really want are just a
mouse for at least and you can see
Java's got kind of a similar system
going to what we do and a mouse pressed
okay so here's what we do every time the
mouse is released we call a mouse
released event we create a new mouse
release event
with an appropriate fee for every button
the X and the y okay and then we just
pull on events with the event and that's
it and then that of course will dispatch
till delays now this should be public
and I'm guessing pressed yeah also be
public okay so we're doing the same
thing from mousepressed
okay that's actually it done right and
then finally we'll have one for motion
so add mouse motion listener new Mouse
emotion listener yeah we can just we
don't have to use the adapter version we
do actually want both of these methods
okay and then similar to what we had
here we kind of create the same thing
except it's going to be a mouse motion
or mouse moved event and all we really
want are the location and whether or not
was dragged obviously if it's been moved
it was moved not dragged however if it
was here it was dragged that's the only
difference
okay there you go done so that's all of
our event setup so it now should
propagate that to all of our players
so now let's learn about how we can use
the event dispatcher to actually
properly handle this stuff using our
example Aaron one on so over here will
just essentially have on event which
overrides our event okay so every time
we get an event it should get sent here
right so that being said if we just kind
of print out event here okay and we add
this layer so let's make some main
method stuff well if I were you just do
the whole thing here so we'll do window
window equals new window we'll call it
advanced it'll be 960 540
window dot adds layer new example layer
and that's probably all we need right
okay so you can see we're getting a ton
of mouse movies events when I click we
get pressed and released event so you
guys can see that in a console if eyes
don't move the mouse we don't get a
mouse moved advance which is good we
don't want to keep sending this hand
over over again basically it seems to be
working pretty well so clicking and you
can see it works um that's pretty
awesome okay you can also add other
events like focus lost and whatnot but
we'll talk about extending this a bit
later because we don't need to talk
about that now so example layout what
I'll do is now that we can't handle the
events I'll our kind of what we want to
do is we want to dispatch them to
different methods based on what event
type they are what we could do
yeah what we could do is have a massive
if statement or a switch statement I
guess there's basically like if ever get
type equals event dot type dot mouse
moves and call this but we don't want to
have that right because that's very
messy so instead what we do is we use
the event dispatcher so we have our
event dispatcher we'll call it a
dispatcher we set this equal to a new
event dispatcher event right and then
what we do is basically we create we can
create a bunch of methods now these have
to be in compliance with basically our
event handler interface right so what's
our Bend handler I had how Eclipse
brings that stuff up first I mean come
on
clearly I don't want that which is a
publicly known event so basically let's
create a public bullying we'll call this
like on the mouse press for example we
have to take in we keep taking a mouse
press event straight away actually
okay and then if that happens we'll say
mousepressed II don't get button for
example just just for now right and then
we'll return false which means that we
we're not blocking other layers mmm no
so basically the way we use this is
pretty simple we say dispatcher dispatch
event type dot which one are we trying
to dispatch the press again you can
actually kind of imply this stuff if
you're using C++ or something but job is
a bit limited so I'm kind of showing you
guys the job way to do this and then you
basically have to have an event handler
which on event calls or returns on mouse
press now this is extremely messy and I
would really really hate writing it like
this especially because if you're doing
a C or C sharp you can literally just
have a function pointer in there and
that's it good news is Java now supports
lambdas so what you can do is pretty
simple you can actually just have a
lambda so event E right and then we'll
just call on mousepressed and then we'll
have to cast it mousepressed event which
we know it's going to be since the type
is mousepressed e and that's it so you
can see how much simpler how much easier
that is then then having than having to
have a full interface and anonymous
inner class creation thing will be add
as well so this is much easy now okay
this is the method that we're calling
event it's it matches these parameters
of course because because of where is it
the event handler which has an event and
then employed you know if that kind of
returns it that's self-explanatory and
then this is what we're calling okay
with these parameters there we go so we
just basically have to do that and so
what happens now is that when I press my
mouse you can see it presses pretty cool
okay so now if I add some more so we'll
have a released and we'll have a moot
I'll call a basically copy and paste
this will have it on us released and
moved so when we move I'll just say
something lat like Mouse moves I'm not
going to spend too much time writing
this code so this has to be a mouse
moved event sorry Mouse for the least
event and we'll move them up here so
unfortunately we can't really infer
anything here we have to cast stuff so
it's a bit mind but that's okay
and this will be released and this will
be moved okay so now we're dispatching
it into the right functions or methods
so we'll just do something like released
+ e dot button and remember we do have
stuff like we do have more information
here like where it was released or where
it was pressed right so I can do
something like that
and if I run this when we move it says
mouse moved when I press and release it
it says exactly what I printed there
okay so it's cool how we kind of get a
location as well and you can put any
information you want yeah you just have
to remember that you have to add it into
the appropriate event class okay however
that may be and when you're dispatching
them from the internal kind of API you
add that information and that's it it's
really really simple and it's awesome
okay so that being said now we've got
this let's make something useful and
I'll demonstrate the I will demonstrate
the kind of bullies that you can return
and how you can use them okay so my plan
here is basically I'm going to make two
layers like with names
I'll give them a color I'll have a box
that I'll render and
we'll have a static final random random
alright so in the constructor well
taking a name for the layout and a fella
which will set up no install extensions
how did I get here get out
no I can't Oh what go away
goodness me that was terrible okay so
color and then we'll make a box which is
just going to be a new rectangle so will
randomize this little bit right I'm not
next to it maybe like 300 400 and then
random dot next int 200 or I should make
the window a bit smaller because it's a
bit too big and width and height
8050 should be okay I'll quickly make
the window bit smaller 640 360 and now
we can put the stuff in so I'll have
like the bottom layer which we have
first which I will make I don't know man
which make it like a blue kind of color
what's a nice blue color
we'll just a new color
two two three three see see that's a
nice color and then we'll just kind of
reverse that for the red and we'll
caught up so Reds on top and blue is on
bottom there we go if we made some
example layers now and then all we want
to do here is kind of render it okay so
to render it
we just need to override the on render
method graphics G okay we'll set a color
well filler it will fill the rectangle
so buffs out Xbox - I I'll start with
box heights all right and then we'll
just draw the label as well which is the
name civil drawers throw it in white add
about box that X plus 5 maybe and box
top wife was 15 maybe tax in Java seems
to be measured from the bottom even
though you like the made the projection
matrix says that that says that the top
is a top left so anyway all the yes
there is a risk of life anyway that's
why this 15 okay so yeah this should be
pretty solid now let's see if we get the
boxes rendering list so we got bottom
top right now let's make these events
met event things actually do something
useful
totally the print the print FS for the
system to either print lines and we'll
get onto it so basically when we press
the mouse okay so we want two variables
when you turn in the previous master
that we're going to make it so that we
can drag the boxes around plus one doing
private building drag eating is false so
px and py a previous acts in previous
why that's just for mouth positions so
we know how much we need to drag and we
can work out deltas and stuff like that
so on mousepressed if box doc contains a
point here which is going to be don't
get x you don't get Y then it means that
we've basically started dragging source
a Dragonball true true so here's the
deal we're actually going to return
dragging okay because what that will do
is it will mean that if we actually do
if we actually do do essentially contain
that point which means that we've
clicked on a box when we started
dragging it we don't want to send the
events two layers further down okay
otherwise we do so I'll demonstrate I'll
toggle these things for you guys and
I'll show you exactly what's happening
so you know it doesn't matter if your
mouse is released or not we'll actually
just set dragging of the files and we'll
just return false we can we
we don't care about blocking I'll
release events for every other layer now
this is the bread and butter of the
actual operation so we'll just bring out
these variables real quick so we don't
have to keep typing get X and get Y all
the time if we're dragging right we're
going to basically work out the Delta
and we'll set off set X equal to X minus
px and box are y equals y minus py
all right so working out the deltas and
then finally we'll set the X equal to X
and P y 2y so that's it we're kind of
updating our previous and then obviously
figuring out the amount that it's
changed here so we'll usually get
something between you know I don't know
what we'll get but it would be between
like negative 30 and 30 for example it
depends how fast you move your mouse so
there we go awesome this should work and
then we'll return dragging mm so that
being said if we now open this up we
should be able to drag these boxes
around or not so it appears I've done
something wrong yeah I did flossed idea
beach balls instead of plus equals it
was always heading it to the Delta now
you can see we can drag these around
okay I'm just clicking on them and I'm
dragging them around all right
pretty cool stuff so what will happen
I shouldn't on that let's put them back
here okay so what will happen now is the
top is obviously always going to be on
top okay now what that means is if I'm
on top and I click on the top layer even
though it's kind of over the bottom
layer it's going to move the top layer
not the bottom layer however if I click
on the bottom layer is going to prove
that ok that's because of the bad system
all right you can see I can't really
move the bottom layer unless I'm
actually clicking on it now if we didn't
do that yeah if we didn't return let's
say we return false what that would mean
is that if these two layers one on top
of each other that should probably be
moving both of them oh well it's because
we're also returning dragging here so
let's return false ok so now you can see
they're both move all right
that's because we're kind of we don't
care if it's on top of what we kind of
what kind of propagating meals like that
so that's one thing you can do however
if I also always always had true on
mouse press for example then that means
that I will never be able to move that
bottom layer yeah except trying I can't
because the top layer is always eating
up holy events okay so you can do some
pretty cool stuff with that so they
should be dragging and that's the
functionality you want so you can see we
now have the ability to block events
from different layers depending on so
depending on anything really but um that
basically just reinforces the fact that
that's how the event system works okay
so that's pretty much it guys I hope you
enjoyed the video if you have any
questions about advanced or anything
just leave them in the comments below
I'll try and reply to as many comments
as I can we will be integrating this
into the game programming series the
next video for the game programming
series okay so next episode of that will
we will integrate this advanced system
into there but that's pretty much it I
just wanted to make a standalone video
so that everyone could watch it
irregardless of irregardless is in a
word regardless of whether or not you
guys are essentially up to date with
gahafer demi series or not so there we
go
events pretty cool this entire code will
be on github but there'll be a link in
the description of this video to this
code so that you can play around with it
yourself and again any questions pop
them below and I hope you guys enjoyed
this video thanks for watching hit a
like button if you enjoyed it and I will
see you guys next time goodbye